foreign
all started out with Drug Money
[Music]
town was built
on coke money
every bit of it
if you did cocaine in America in the 80s
it almost certainly passed through Miami
Miami's cocaine City the main cocaine
Transit point between the American
Mainland and the Bahamas millions of
dollars worth were smuggled in by this
man alone I got paid 500 000 a trip I
wouldn't do a friendly list
rival gangs battled for their share of
the drug profits
making Miami the murder capital of
America and inspiring my favorite TV
show as a kid
this was my first glimpse into the
cocaine underworld I was fascinated by
the money the violence
the Larger than Life characters
and of course Crockett's fashion choices
I had no idea that decades later the
Miami smuggling scene would be hot again
and that I'd be the one chasing the
traffickers they're starting to bring
the old roots back with connections off
to Central South America this is a story
about one of the most infamous and
intractable smuggling routes on the
planet
foreign
[Music]
us War on Drugs how is cocaine as cheap
and plentiful as ever cops don't catch
anybody ma'am people tell
let's go let's go we were spotting
and who are the people putting their
lives on the line to deliver Americans
their preferred party drug
I'm heading on a 3 000 mile Journey from
green leaves to White Lines to find out
[Music]
police checkpoint
okay
when your job is reporting on black
markets a few checkpoints are to be
expected
but nothing stirs the butterflies in the
belly quite like the last checkpoint
the one before you step into ungoverned
territory
like this
is
as we clear the checkpoint we enter a
lawless region that produces roughly
one-fifth of the world's cocaine
the brain
[Music]
excellent
my guide to this world is my friend
Ceviche who lived in the rain for many
years
right there
locals here in the rain have been
growing coca for thousands of years
but this isn't your typical farming
community
foreign
vigilante militians like this are the de
facto law of the land
[Music]
skoka Farmers turned soldiers are
trained to defend their communities
[Music]
and their crop
coca leaves okay so okay
saying I should just chew it not swallow
it it tastes like Leaf um
here in Peru it's actually legal to grow
and sell coca leaves it only becomes
illegal if you're processing those
leaves into cocaine is
foreign
the militias formed in response to The
Shining path a ruthless communist group
that Rose to power in the 1980s its
members have waged a decades-long civil
war to overthrow the Peruvian government
The Shining path controls key smuggling
roots and has been known to attack
communities to expand its territory
that's how the group makes its money
extorting Growers makers and Smugglers
for protection or safe Passage
is
[Music]
the politics in the brain are
complicated nothing to fund their fight
against The Shining path and to support
their families these Farmers sell their
coca Harvest and they never ask
questions about the buyer's intended use
but the truth is nearly 94 of coca
leaves in the frame go to drug
traffickers
here the drug trade is controlled by
small family clients who operate
independently
and all of them are suspicions of
Outsiders
when locals see a bunch of Gringos they
think we're American law enforcement
that's why I'm leaning on Ceviche to
help me get access to the next step in
the process
services
turns out that one of ceviche's former
passengers is still active in the
cocaine trade
he's part of a family clan that buys
coca leaves and processes them into
cocaine paste
his contact agreed to meet but gave us
very little information we were told to
take the one road out of town and wait
for further instructions
so we're driving for an hour up the
mountain in these dirt roads we're
heading to meet the dueno the owner of a
drug operation who's given us a green
light to film his lab in the jungle
all I know is that I've been promised to
see the place where cocaine begins it's
3 000 mile Journey to the U.S but for
now everyone is just nervous about
getting there we've been told that every
time a car approaches or we go through
these towns that have lights that we
should hide our faces because they don't
want to see you know any Gringos in this
area because it would raise suspicions
serious quite dangerous
even though we've gotten permission to
see this cocaine lab to get there we
have to pass through land controlled by
other clans and militias who have no
idea who we are or what we're up to
so I'm a little Stardust when in the
middle of a deserted Road
[Music]
a man suddenly appears out of the
darkness
trying to figure out who this guy is
[Music]
the chemist the key figure in the whole
operation was standing on a mountain
Road in the pitch dark
sometimes you can't make this stuff up
so they're checking the area to make
sure that everything is safe
okay shut off all lights and here it is
the entry into the jungle
employees
[Music]
he's saying that the town close by if
they see us they can create problems to
all of us
these labs are the economic engines for
the local communities without them there
would be little demand for coca leaves
that's why villagers are so protective
we're basically a threat to their
livelihood
[Music]
the chemist has made me promise that I
won't reveal the location
I told him it's not a problem
I can barely see my own feet
wow this is it it's right here wow
foreign
the cocaine pit the starting point for
such a storied Black Market trade ranks
up there
but as the reporter High wears off I
realize that the whole process boils
down to brute labor and simple chemistry
[Music]
so they've been doing this for three
days and now this is the final step
which they mix it with salt
it takes 400 kilos almost 900 pounds of
cocoa leaves to make one kilo of cocaine
they are soaked in water acid and bleach
which draws the drugs out of the leaves
and now it's ready to be moved on to
smaller containers to the laboratorium
foreign
here in this makeshift lab they'll start
the purification process
Ary
[Music]
researchers discovered how to extract
cocaine from coca leaves over 150 years
ago and Americans got their first taste
of the drug in Coca-Cola back in the
19th century
before it was banned by the federal
government in 1914.
it's a really really intense smell
is
Gasolina
see
to purify cocaine in the middle of the
Peruvian jungle they figured out how to
extract the drug using simple
and a whole lot of gasoline
in this lab each batch requires 70
gallons
foreign
gasoline with each toxic additive the
drug becomes more and more concentrated
and what they're doing is that they're
removing the top of it which is the fuel
and the bottom is a clear sort of liquid
and that's where the drugs remain as you
see it's pretty dark
and that's all the gasoline
and the clear part now underneath
it's okay
the drugs right there
so they call that clear liquid they call
it the soup
[Music]
he asked me if I wanted to try it
TV oh check this out
this is amazing
it's crazy to think that only weeks from
now this Jungle Soup will disappear up
some Americans nostrils
now it's time for the final step
a splash of ammonia to solidify the
drugs
okay they have to speed it up we have to
speed it up guys
with so many livelihoods depending on
this lab ceviche's friend is taking a
massive risk giving us a peek behind the
curtain
so when the chemist disappears for a
moment I begin to worry
[Music]
okay guys we have to go right now
let's go let's go
we were spotted by somebody up on the
road they said that we have to get him
to the car and get out of here
to go fast
no no no stand intro are they all inside
[Music]
thankfully we escape without incident
but the drugs long journey North is only
just beginning
it's a new day in the rain
last night's coca paste has hardened
into bricks
the next challenge
getting them out of the valley
the easiest way would be by plane
Peruvian military now has permission to
shoot down suspected drug flights
driving the coke out would also work but
the roads here are littered with police
checkpoints
so that's given way to the preferred
method of transport
in a backpack
the same guys who ran the lab ask us to
meet them outside of town at a Trailhead
that leads up into the Andes
copy that we're uh we're following the
Convoy we're right behind the other two
cars
okay okay
we're here
okay
they are known as mochileros the Spanish
word for Backpacker
their backpacks are filled with bricks
and powder
they are the Sherpas of the cocaine
world
I was surprised to learn that the
chemist from last night is also a
mochilero
is
15 minutes ago and I'm already exhausted
and I'm not carrying 10 kilos on my back
foreign
[Music]
rival Clans corrupt cops thieves of all
kinds
it's the wild west out on the trails
I asked what would happen if they get
attacked
[Music]
yes
I'm following the cocaine highway from
the mountains of Peru to the nightclubs
of Miami
it's 4am and I'm embedded with a group
of young men
risking their lives to hike 30 kilos out
of the rain Valley
so this is the main stuff they take a
can of tuna Saltines they have a plastic
that they use to cover themselves in
case it rains and then alcohol which
they say helps with altitude sickness
because they're growing high up the
mountain
so this here is worth nine hundred
dollars each a kilo in the US once it's
processed it's worth twenty five
thousand dollars foreign
that means these guys are carrying about
000 worth of Rocco Kane
[Music]
Peruvian cocaine paste some of the most
sought after in the world
the same bricks that Escobar would fly
into Colombia to process and to powder
it looks so unassuming
it's hard to imagine the trail of
violence left in its wake
up
again
[Music]
um
let's see throw a set of models
[Music]
is
see
yes
you say
s
thank you
they're getting anxious while leaving
watching these young men pack I'm
feeling conflicted
I know what they're doing is illegal and
that the drug they're carrying has
caused millions of families around the
world to suffer
but after spending two days with them
I can't help but be concerned for their
safety they're just kids
only a few years older than my own son
seems so unfair that the lack of options
in the frame means they have to risk
their lives just so Americans can get
their cheap high
so they said they're going to walk for
12 more hours
and then uh and then rest and then
continue for a day and a half more okay
[Music]
we make plans to meet up at the end of
their Journey
but I'm worried
Anything could happen on the trail
[Music]
as the mochileros rise out of the valley
Rises as well
theirs is just the first leg of a global
distribution Network
if the mochillero survived the hike it
will sell to a new owner we'll smuggle
the drugs by car into Lima and then head
north
each time the drugs change hands the
price jumps Smugglers must account for
the real costs of transport and the risk
plus each will take their share of the
profits
eventually the cocaine passes through
Ecuador to Colombia my next stop
[Music]
at first glance turbo looks like any
other Caribbean fishing town
but just beneath the surface
[Music]
people say the life improve is partying
it's having sex
the dream car to park yard and you know
soon you might be at that man out on the
streets
because nearly everyone here also living
in a dangerous world
when code is mainly depopulated by
fishermen but still cocaine business is
the main business
Oliver schmieg is a German
photojournalist who spent decades in
Colombia documenting the drug trade
what we have to understand is like
mostly drugs going from Colombia to the
U.S they are passing through Turbo
if you want to run sparkling routes
right through the old term that's like
the perfect place
it's very easy to recruit people who are
able to drive a cargo boss
what are the chances we could see one of
these boats or even ride in one of them
you're 21 years the Cavalier is access
to drug cartels and it's just a matter
of
how much they might trust in US
Oliver works his contacts and directs me
to a dock on the edge of town
which I'm not allowed to show on camera
but just as he promised I met by two
cocaine smugglers in a boat
[Music]
foreign
the boats are empty
and Smugglers agreed to talk about their
work but they won't let me near the
product the multi-million dollar
payloads they move are too valuable to
risk showing them off to foreign
journalists
foreign
[Music]
Smugglers use these low-tech fiberglass
boats to outmaneuver the Colombian
military and its Ally the U.S Coast
Guard
radar waves which easily detect metals
can only get an extremely weak signal of
fiberglass making boats like this
practically invisible
foreign
maintenance
apples
okay there's a boat over there
okay it's a fisherman but they're they
were saying before that if anything if
any boat approaches that they had
immediately take off their mask and we
put the cameras down and we just say
we're doing a show about tourism okay
they're not feeling very comfortable
okay
they're gonna take off their masks
yo
I'm in a boat off the coast of Colombia
with two very nervous cocaine smokers
they were spooked by some passing
fishermen so they're taking me into
deeper waters where they say it's safer
to speak
so he was saying that all these
fishermen everyone here basically works
for the clan so if they see him talking
to us they'll go inform him and that can
be dangerous for them
[Music]
Anthony
is Colombia's largest and most powerful
drug cartel made up of mostly hardened
paramilitary Fighters and wanted war
criminals how violent exactly is the
Glendale golfer well I mean you have to
be quite careful obviously you're
dealing with criminals at the end of the
day so like one and a half year called
that just shut down the whole village so
they are quite powerful like the kind of
Supercar top it might be even a more
powerful than groups in Mexico for
example
I know that getting access to cartel
leadership is a bigger ask for days it
didn't look like it was going to happen
and then out of nowhere we got the green
light we just made the first right guys
we're all together let's go
in the car ahead of us is one of the
clandel golfo's top commanders in this
region
we have no idea where we're going but
we're following the commander
so there are a couple of uh
see soldiers right up here
and there's a cough up there too okay
but with the military everywhere we're
all a bit on edge let's try to get in
very quickly here okay
this is it it's a little ranch house
okay
one two can you hear me one two three
four five okay we're good
even though the commander and his
bodyguard trust Oliver this is the first
time we've met and they're skeptical
s
I show him some photos of my past work
and hope that will convince him that I'm
not law enforcement
[Music]
okay by looking at something they
eventually agreed to the interview
okay
in the traditional business world he
might be considered a VP of operations
is helping to manage a complicated
Global criminal Network
out of a farmhouse in the Colombian
Countryside
that's a weekly shipment of cocaine
worth 25 million dollars on the streets
of Miami
in control
Antonio Colombia
the clando golf was top Commander
otoniel is Colombia's Public Enemy
Number One with a 5 million dollar
bounty on his head he's notorious for
assassinating government officials and
ordering the detonation of a grenade in
the middle of a nightclub
he demands complete loyalty from his
soldiers
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
as we talk I begin to realize that even
when you're near the top of the cartel
food chain safety is no guarantee
[Music]
foreign
in the last few years cocaine
trafficking in Colombia has reached
record levels
what these men tell me this rise has
been anything but glamorous
yet the country is the distribution
center for the global cocaine trade
from here roughly half the supply is
shipped to Europe Africa Asia and
Australia
the other half will end up in the United
States
[Music]
that's if Smugglers can evade these guys
we just spotted a Northbound vessel
heading from the south and a known drug
trafficking area
usually with a vessel that Si's over 40
feet has cabins spaces that you could
actually hide a large amount of
Narcotics we're gonna board a vessel
that is suspected of narcotic smuggling
you're going to encounter a master he
may or may not be armed watch out for
each other your job gain compliance
however means necessary
in the last five years the U.S Coast
Guard has seized a record amount of
cocaine at Sea we're here today to
offload 14 200 pounds about 11 tons 20
metric tons of pure uncut cocaine worth
over 190 million dollars
[Music]
the drug traffic organizations are
creative and they're always looking for
ways to elude detection that could be a
go fast vessel that could be a low
profile vessel it could be a
semi-submersible
submersible that could be legitimate
commercial traffic
valve we're gonna scramble the boarding
team together get them on the small boat
to go over and investigate and see
what's going on
without enough to figure out what's
actually physically going on
until you put boots on Deck
the most dangerous parts of an officer's
job when they board what they suspect is
a drug-running vote
smugglers in this situation have a
difficult choice
abandon their cargo and face the
cartel's Wrath
we'll try to outrun the red white and
blue
Sky let me see your hands
uh without reaching for touching you got
any weapons on board
all right we're gonna come on board and
uh do uh inspect On Your Vessel next you
guys are in compliance with all federal
rules and regulations for a vessel this
size
141 miles from Miami the Coast Guard has
intercepted a suspected smuggling boat
[Music]
more traditional drug smuggling routes
in the Caribbean are having an uptick in
activity
you have non-stop boat traffic and some
of them could be legitimately fishing
but also have a drugs hidden on board
cocaine accounts for 94 of all narcotics
seized at Sea after the boarding we
discovered that the vessel was Charter
For Hire just in a suspicious area
everybody on board was compliant and
it's you know the best outcome you could
have in a situation when you're talking
about safety
no drugs are found the Coast Guard moves
on
catching drug Runners on the high seas
is an elusive game with cat and mouse
we're operating an area larger than the
continental United States now imagine
you have three or four police cars
patrolling the continental United States
that's essentially what the Coast Guard
with our ships is doing
plus out here it's just pivotal before
those drugs make it towards the U.S and
can be dispersed throughout the
different states
with such a large area to patrol it's
impossible to catch them all in all the
efforts every day doing the mission we
only get 10 percent of known drugs that
are being moved towards the United
States the remaining 90 of cocaine slips
past undetected
heading to Miami under the cover of
Darkness
40 years after cocaine built this
Skyline the drug money is still pouring
in
this convertible is a tribute to my
childhood crashes
Crockett and tubs
as I cruise towards South Beach to meet
a coke dealer I'm actually thinking back
to the final episode of Miami Vice when
they decide to turn in their badges
because they realize that the War on
Drugs is unwinnable
after 3 000 miles on the cocaine Highway
I'd be lying if I said I didn't wander
the same
do you have some of the stuff you sell
with I will do something for you you
have some in your pocket yeah I bought a
couple bags with me
just looks like regular patterns just a
couple bags
and Dana you know
it looks like a Cigar Case yeah for sure
that's what I keep it in you know it's a
little more inconspicuous
the way I make most of my money is like
20 bags I'll come to South Beach and I
sell a 20 bag for forty dollars
which is multiply that's all
on a good day I'll get two ounces for
about two thousand bucks and if you sell
it all how much money can you make
about five thousand almost six how long
does it take you to sell that
um that'll be going in three days so you
can make three thousand dollars in three
days essentially a thousand dollars a
day yeah about that is it pure cocaine
that you sell I mean it's all right yeah
it'll keep people up for days at a time
for sure
Beach loves it in the clubs everybody
you know South Beach is cocaine and this
year in this generation that's what
everybody wants
everybody doesn't fun they come to Miami
they want to party in the party city
that's what it's all about
it's just after midnight and the dealer
agrees to let me watch him work
but only if I play by his rules
so we can't have our cameras out there
and the only way he agreed for us to
film this was just we'd stay in the car
and we'd film it from here
how do you go about selling it
he's got to be low-key
you gotta be ahead of your game you know
because people try to set you up it's
they're stuff yeah you got to be
prepared for sure
sometimes when I deal with my weight you
know I have to bring a pistol with me
stuff like that because people try to
rob you what kind do you have a 357
Magnum with a six inch barrel
it's one of my favorites
have you used it
I wouldn't want to comment on that
he's got a phone call
and he's walking somewhere
and then he just went in there somewhere
I do mostly everything right now just do
text messages I have like a burner form
it's an untraceable phone okay he's
walking no this way
so I'm just gonna check on him see
what's up
40 bucks
right there inside the pizza place
you just went into the bathroom gave her
and she gave you the money and that was
it okay
how many people do you sell to in a week
more or less you think in a week
75 people maybe wow that's a lot
product so and so
aren't you afraid of getting hot
I mean now I am because you have a
family and stuff like that but
still got to feed them you know what I'm
saying got to take care of the family
and it means necessary that's all
it's a small sacrifice right keep a
little bail money to the side
be all right I'm ready for whatever
happens
very few people know the journey a kilo
of cocaine makes to get to the United
States or the hands that it touches
along the way
foreign
but the path it follows from beginning
to end is shaped by simple economics
that's as clear on the streets of Miami
as it is on the boats of Colombia
or the trails of Peru
Pakistan
they're here back in the frame the
chemist and the would-be dentist have
just made their drop
another 30 kilos are headed North
Carolina
little security is
trouble because
[Music]
again
foreign
[Music]